doing it although the other committees
are doing it we're just preparing it
for live stream right now my computer
says it's
streaming live on youtube for 62 people
on
so mike you think we're about ready to
start there's oh there's peter
missing dave danielson i'm gonna give
dave danielson a quick call
okay thank you lynn i'm just looking up
the number should
yeah i think that's i'm just looking one
more time
let's see if there's anyone david's
father-in-law died um
last week so it could be he's a little
um not available maybe
so right now we have 21 or the 22
members just representing danielson
so it's up to the committee how they'd
like to proceed
well why don't we get started and maybe
lynn can
can be in touch with dave and he can
enter remember i have that statement to
read so that takes it
that takes a little while okay so
good afternoon uh this is mary jane
walner uh chair
could you hear me i was trying to call
you
oh i'm sorry
okay let's start over good afternoon
this is mary jane walner chair of the
house finance committee
and um i welcome all of you to the
meeting the may 21st meeting
of the new hampshire house finance
committee
we will be having an exact session
executing on a number
a number of bills that we have before us
before we get started
i want to read through a checklist to
ensure that the meeting that we are
holding is in compliance with the right
to know law
and as chair of the house finance
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the code 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
as extended pursuant to executive order
2020-09
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location
to observe and listen contemporaneously
to this meeting
which was was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we are
one providing public access to the
meeting
by telephone with additional access
possible by video and other electronic
means we are utilizing
zoom video webinar for this electronic
meeting
all members of the committee and
selected legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen
to the meeting on zoom youtube
or phone following the directions and
links
provided on the general court website at
http colon backslash backslash
www dot gen
court dot state dot new hampshire
dot u s backslash house
backslash online meetings
backslash finance backslash finance
may 21 2020
executive pd
pdf two
providing public notice of the necessary
information
for accessing the meeting we previously
gave notice to the meeting
of the necessary information for us
accessing the meeting
in the house calendar three
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if anyone has a problem please email
hcs dot
state dot nh dot u
s or call 603
271 3600
number four adjourning the meeting if
the meet if the public is unable to
access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes are taken
all votes taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
and let's start the meeting by taking a
roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please
also state where where their
where they are and if anyone else is in
the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law and i'll ask
representative rogers to call the role
um representative walner
representative wallner is here i'm at my
home
in concord and i am alone in the room
representative hewitt um representative
hewitt is here
i'm in my office in the basement of my
home and i'm all alone
representative rogers i am here in
concord
um i am alone with the exception of my
dog romeo
representative nordgren represent
nordgren is here i'm
at my home in hanover new hampshire and
i'm here with my
golden retriever cleo representative
leishman
good afternoon i am alone in
peterborough
representative bucco uh yes thank you i
i um i'm at home in conway and i'm here
alone
representative hatch i'm alone at my
home in gorham
representative ford i'm in easton i'm
home alone
representative lovejoy hi i'm
i'm in stratham at my home alone and
other than the dog may come
through a few times representative waltz
i am in my home in beau and i am alone
in this room
representative heath hi there i'm mary
heath
i'm here in manchester and i'm home
alone
representative martin representative
joelle martin
in milford and i'm in my home office
alone
representative murray good afternoon i
am at home in newcastle
in my little office space my husband may
be in and out he's doing some work
outside so he may be coming in and out
of the door
and i have my dog representative weiler
i'm in kingston i'm in my home in this
room alone
representative over i'm here
i'm home my cat and i are currently
fighting over who owns the
camera on the tv so if he goes away
i'll be able to turn the video back on
but he's standing on the
on
i apologize apologize for the amount of
time it took me to get on
representative thanos i am here in
laconia and i am alone in my study
representative hennessey
she's here representative hennessey
we did have her i saw her
she was logging on and off i wonder if
she's having troubles
yeah she just dropped off um but we'll
keep an eye for her
maybe she's got my cat trouble
all right we'll come back to it
representative barry i'm in my merrimack
penthouse
along with this the squirrels and the
fisher cats
i hope there's no butchering going on
representative petrie
right uh representative petra here in
farmington with my dog
hopefully nobody must be
can you speak up represent petrie can
you hear me is that better
that's better okay uh i'm here
in farmington my dog hey representative
erf
um alone and where where
yes sir representative greene
i'm home alone in hudson with no pets
let me go back representative hennessey
have you joined us again
sorry yes representative hennessey i am
home in littleton with my two minor
children and i'm having very bad
wi-fi today also i spoke with uh
representative danielson right before
the call and he was going to be trying
to call in
we have him now he came on when you left
us we can keep you both at the same time
it'll be great hopefully thank you
all right we have everyone in attendance
madam chairman
great thank you representative rogers um
i just wanted to um
mike i believe we're going to have
everyone muted and we're going to use
the
the hands up is that correct
yes okay so um
does everyone remember how to to do the
hands up so that mike can
recognize you and then let me know
who has their hands up remind me please
okay can someone could we remind
representative barry how to
where that is yeah let me try to um
are you what are you using represented
barrier
ipad a laptop
click click on participants at the
bottom of the screen that says
participants
not on my screen maybe on youtube on the
top right go up until you get down there
i have i have a leave
record share screen participants that's
it participants
and now at the bottom of that list it'll
say raise hand
really click on that
okay now i get all of you folks
and that's the participants where does
it say raise your hand
so let's let's start um the meeting this
morning we're going to this afternoon
we're going to start with
division 2 and the first bill that we
have
this afternoon is house bill
and i will call on uh representative
hatch to make the motion i
am and to speak to the motion i hope
that everybody or
i'm sorry uh representative lovejoy yeah
okay representative um i hope everyone
has
the agenda before the in front of them
janet sent it out
we're lucky we have janet back with us
now and she did send this
um out to you earlier today so everyone
should have the um
should have the um agenda that we're
and that we'll be working on okay okay
uh representative lovejoy would you like
to speak to
12 years yeah thank you madam chair we
are division one not division two
that's okay i'm sorry
all right when um division one
held a work session on this bill on
march third that was before cobig 19
changed all of our lives and
significantly changed the finances of
the state of new hampshire
so instead of the motion that division 1
had originally planned
i move interim study and would like to
speak to my motion
and i think uh representative ober would
was willing to second that you can call
she is muted right now if you could ask
her if she
would delicious to second
should be unmuted i will second
thank you representative love joy
of calling you making the move to us
yes um this bill called for a study
committee that would need to report out
by november 1st
with the covid 19 situation it doesn't
make sense to require
any more study committees the original
this
bill also had a fiscal note of 100 000
which we were going to reduce to 10 000
but at this time um we do know that we
have a large fiscal hole that is going
to
need to be filled and funding new
endeavors at this point
um we didn't feel was was warranted uh
so we moved for interim study
thank you discussion representative ober
would you like to speak to this
man chairman i concur with what the
chair of division one said
thank you any further discussion on
um house bill 1235 the motion is
interim study
i tried to raise my hand oh okay
um representative barry has his hand up
yes thank you thank you madam sheriff
i believe a similar bill was was uh
contemplated a couple of sessions ago
and
the concern that i had at the time was
that we're starting to interfere with
the collective bargaining agreement
i think that's a that's a
actually the wrong way to go and
by the time we get out of this pandemic
we're going to be finding
considerable number of people who'd be
willing to have a government job and the
benefits
so i even even interim study i think is
a waste of the taxpayers money thank you
thank you representative barry further
comments
discussion
no hands up and i apologize
representative barry i thought you were
just practicing
so but there are no other hands up
see no other hands um i will ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is um
interim study house bill 1235
okay um representative hewitt yes
here you said yes i said
i said yes okay i'm sorry i couldn't
hear you correctly well the equipment
didn't get started fast enough
representative rogers votes yes
representative nordgren
yes representative leashman
representative leishman
yes representative hatch yes
representative ford
yes representative lovejoy yes
representative waltz yes representative
heath
yes representative martin yes
representative murray yes representative
weiler
yes representative ober yes
yeah yeah representative spanos
yeah representative barry
no representative petrie
yes representative earth
yes representative greene yes
representative wallner yes
madam chairman the vote is 22 yeses and
one no
i'd recommend the consent calendar
yes any uh thank you representative
barry representative barry
recommends consent uh any objection to
that
seeing no objection we'll put that one
on consent thank you for that
and let's move on now to house bill
1647 this is still a
um division one bill and i will um ask
uh representative lovejoy to address the
bill
thank you madam chair um i would like to
move
ought to pass with an amendment um
i think everyone should have the
amendment the amendment is
two five 2020-12511 h uh
this amendment does only one thing it
changes
the amendment i second it and who's the
i
uh hatch i'm sorry you have to say your
names because i can't always write and
see
the same time okay i'm sorry this is uh
representation
second thank you
this uh this amendment does only one
thing it moves the
effective date out to july first
20 2021 therefore this bill would not
have
any effect on the current biennium
budget
and this would allow the governor and
legislator legislature
to decide whether to provide the
necessary appropriation in the next
budget
and decide whether to allow or restrict
the judicial council to seek additional
funding
through fiscal
so the um first
we will take a look at the amendment uh
representative
hatch do you want to um
no that's fine i i concur with the chair
that's
thank you is there any other other other
comments
on the amendment
representative ober has her hand up yes
representative ober
thank you ma'am chairman i can't
concur with this for a lot of reasons we
did hold one work session
but the division was unable at the time
because we were not ready to take a vote
at all so we took
no vote on this bill in a work session
and we were going to schedule
another work session and we all know
it's not
our division chairman's fault that that
did not happen
but there are a lot of unanswered
questions about this bill
that we need to examine before it
becomes actually state
law right now it has
judicial council will pay for labs being
done by
safety we needed to bring safety in to
see if there were
grants they could get because we all
know they get a lot of grants if we sit
on fiscal you know how much money
safety can bring in to do some things we
need to know why judicial council would
be paying for labs that another agency
is responsible for
we were not able to get from the agency
a real
amount of finances we do that agency
both
a favor and a disservice
we say to them oh gee you run out of
money
come to fiscal and we'll give you more
and this particular agency has come to
fiscal a number of times this year
as we know to get additional funding but
that does two things
it gives them a crutch that they get so
that they don't really
fund we don't get real financial
information from
at the la at the last fiscal meeting
where they brought
an increase in funding i actually worked
with them quite a while
and they really didn't know how much
money they needed but when we went
through what they
actually needed for additional funding
they were willing to cut
their 250 000 request by a hundred
thousand dollars
so we really need to work with them and
with a couple of other agencies before
this becomes law because you put it in
law
you really are supposed to fund it i
don't believe
in putting things into law and then
suspending which we've done
in hb2 a number of times and we have
done that
because in every case finance has not
had the money to fund that
we've had to make a conscious decision
with the agency as what the priorities
were
and what we would suspend so that they
did not get
a negative performance audit because
they weren't doing their jobs because we
didn't give them the funding
so i can't support this motion i'm not
going to be able to support the bill
it's unfortunate that we had the
pandemic and the division did not have
the time
to do the thorough thoughtful
examination we normally do and again
this is not
part of our chairman in any way the
legislature has been suspended she was
willing to continue working on it
it just didn't happen this year thank
you
thank you representative ober um further
further comments on the amendment
which is love joy
madam chair i don't know if we're
supposed to be speaking to the full bill
right now or just the amendment
um if if you wish to wait till after we
vote on the amendment to talk about
the full bill i would do that then yes
i think we need to have a vote on the
amendment and then we'll
talk on the whole bill okay thank you
does that sound good to everybody
so do i have any more comments on the
amendment
i think we need to have a vote we need
to have a vote and i need to
um have uh representative rogers call
the role on the amendment
representative hewitt representative
hillard votes yes representative roswigs
votes yes representative nordgren
representative nordgren votes yes
representative leishman
yes representative bucco yes
representative hatch representative
votes yes representative ford
yes representative lovejoy
yes representative waltz uh
enthusiastically votes yes
representative heath representative
heath votes yes
martin yes representative murray
representative murray votes yes
representative
no representative ober
no representative danielson
no spanos
excuse me representative spanos no
thank you
hennessy votes no representative barry
enthusiastically no
no representative no
representative greene no representative
walner
yes adam sherman the vote is 13 yeses
and nine no's
vote is uh 13-9 the amendment
the amendment passes and now uh
representative lovejoy i'll recognize
you for the for the vote on the full
bill
thank you uh what this bill does is it
extends the
current practice of where a a
prisoner could request dna testing
there is quite a procedure they are
actually making a petition
to the superior court if they meet
i think it's the five criteria the
superior court
could then um appoint counsel for them
what this bill does is it extends that
ability for somebody who is in prison to
do it to somebody who is
no longer in prison somebody who was out
on parole
or potentially even whose term has um
her
sentences has expired uh
from the the lawyers who are involved in
in this sort of thing they've petitioned
or they've
asked everybody involved whether or not
how many cases that anybody knows about
the only case that that anyone could
come up with was one potential
case over the last 10 years it is not
expected
to be a a drain on
on the judicial council but we moved it
off to
uh to next year to the next biennium
because currently the um
the digital council has had to come back
to fiscal already so in effect they have
already
spent their budget so even if there was
one case they theoretically could not do
it within their budget
uh we have always underfunded um the
judicial council
in our when we do our budget because we
know that they can come to
um to the fiscal committee uh probably
not a good practice but it is one that
we have
uh we have been doing so this bill
just extends that process to somebody
who is
out on parole or whose uh sentence has
been completed
was that enough to pass motion
second set motion thank you
representative hatch seconds the motion
of octopass is amended
and i do see uh representative walls has
her hand up
thank you madam chairman
the fundamental process that we are
allowed to prosecute people under in
this country is justice
and we know sadly that our justice
system has failed a number of times and
more recently in the last couple of
decades dna
evidence has proven over and over again
that our justice
has made mistakes and i think that this
the foundation of our system
being fairness we owe it to people who
have been to convicted
if they believe they're innocent to
provide the opportunity to have dna
examined
and determine whether or not they were
unjustly convicted
and i think that allowing this to happen
passing this bill
furthers that end and i think it's so
fundamental to our very system in this
country
i think from my point of view we have a
moral obligation to do it just to
for the foundation of our system so that
is why i enthusiastically had supported
it before and i continue to
because i think it is a part of
fundamental justice
that we do this thank you representative
walsh
further further discussion of the bill i
see no other hands up
at this point um so i will ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is
ought to pass as amended on
house bill 1647.
[Music]
representative votes yes representative
rogers votes yes representative nordgren
representative norgren votes yes
representative leishman
yes representative bucco yes
representative hatch yes
representative ford yes representative
lovejoy
yes representative waltz yes
representative heath representative
heath votes yes
representative martin yes representative
murray
yes represent weiler no
representative ober no representative
danielson
no representative spanos
no representative hennessy
tennessee votes no representative barry
no representative petrie no
representative no representative greene
no representative walner yes
madam chairman the vote is 13 yeses 9
no's
the motion passes uh 13
to nine and we won't place that one on
consent
okay madam
yeah i'll do the motion on the next bill
also
okay we'll move on to house bill 1708
and i will call on uh representative
lovejoy
for a motion thank you madam chair
uh division one voted um ought to pass
with amendment
um hopefully you all have the amendment
it is amendment 2020-1018-h
presented by representative ober
i move the amendment first
discussion of the amendment
you want a second yes a second please
and then we'll have discussion i would
second the amendment
thank you representative ober
representative over um
seconds the uh motion
discussion um just a description of what
the amendment is
the amendment makes one um one change to
line
30 of the bill and it adds um
it's on it adds a few words
this is the the salary and benefits
costs for this position
shall be a change a charge against the
liquor fund
and it adds as described in section 13
of this act
and that is the only change is adding
those words as described in
section 13 of this act if i might madam
chairman
yes representative ober um we had two
sections section 12 and section 13 they
were both written
in ways and means and represent almi
came and worked with us and approved of
this
amendment and basically what we did was
uh
this amendment takes the language
already existing
in section 13 and moves it up so it is
also applies to section 12
to make it clear that the policy
committee ways and means actually wanted
it to say that we were
we had the discussion because with 13
following 12 and 13 ever so slightly
different than 12
we worked with her and came up with this
representative any further discussion
we're discussing um the amendment
any further discussion
though i will ask representative rogers
to call the role on the amendment
representative votes yes representative
rogers votes yes representative norgren
representative yes representative
oh yes senate hatch yes
representative ford yes representative
lovejoy
yes representative walt yes
representative heath representative
heath voceas
representative martin yes representative
murray
yes representative weiler yes
representative yes representative
danielson
yeah represents spanish
yeah davidson hennessey
yes representative petry yes
representative yes
representative greene yes
representative wildner yes
um if unanimously that's 22 yeses zero
knows
i don't know i think there's 23
[Music]
the motion for the amendment passes 23-0
i miss the good old days when we could
just look out there and see everybody's
hand up
on these amendments so
now uh representative lovejoy do you
want to make him
the final motion on this bill yeah i'd
like to move out to pass with amendments
and speak to my emotion
second dimension representative lovejoy
moves on to pass with amendment and
representative hatch seconds
did i speak the motion yes thank you
madam chair
uh this bill was a bill that went
through ways and means ways and means
worked uh
very hard on this bill and it passed out
of ways and means uh with a bipartisan
20 to nothing uh vote what this bill
does is it sets um fees
for um
retail establishments that itself
tobacco it also
brings in the e-cigarettes uh so it's
giving additional
responsibilities to the um liquor
commission
as part of its um uh
its position of um
oversight oversight of these uh of these
establishments
it also allows for two additional
um investigators to be paid for by these
fees
uh the bill is is self-funding uh the
liquor commission cannot hire the first
new investigator until they have
collected
least fees covering 50 percent of all
cost of that position
and they cannot hire the second one
until they have collected fees that
that cover the entire first position and
50 percent of the second position
that's all thank you further discussion
see none i do want to make a correction
um and i want to check with
representative uh rogers about this
i think when i announced it i announced
on the amendment i think i announced
23 to zero and i
think you were correct i think it was
22. i think i we only have 22 people so
it's
right so it should have been so i want
to go back
and make that correction um i do know
that i said 23 but it should have been
to zero on the amendment and um if
there's no further discussion
i will ask uh representative rogers to
father i'm trying to raise my hand we do
have a hand
representative barry representative
barry
thank you thank you madam chair uh from
from my perspective it's a
it's another fee slash tax increase and
more bureaucracy so i'm going to vote
against it
thank you representative barry any
further discussion
okay i don't see any other hands up at
this time
okay correct um i will ask
representative rogers to call the role
representative hewitt representative
hewitt votes yes
representative rogers votes yes
representative nordgren
representative nordgrenville gs
representative leishman
yes representative bucco representative
bucco voces
patch yes representative ford
yes representative lovejoy yeah
representative waltz yes representative
heath
yes representative martin yes
representative murray yes representative
weiler
yes representative ober
no excuse me you said no
i said no of course
representative danielson no
no it was in hennessy
no representative barry
no thank you representative petrie
no representative irf no
representative greene no representative
walner
yes
[Music]
the vote being 14 yes and eight no
the vote is 14 to 8
and that will go on the regular calendar
let's move on now to division
two thank you division one
division two uh their first bill in
division two
is house bill 1549
and i will call on representative
keith thank you madam chair i would like
to introduce house bill
1549 um that establishes an office of
school counseling and psychology and at
this time i would like to propose
amendment um one zero two three
h representative keith
um is proposing
amendment one
is it one zero two three eight yes
yes okay i hope you will you all have it
you all have the amendment
representative ford has her hand
yes second four okay
seconds the motion um representative
heath would you like to speak to your to
the bill
here um to the amendment thank you madam
chair i would
um the amendment um simply um
enacts the commissioner of the
department of education
to request an appropriation well first
of all it um
withdraws the appropriation um from the
bill
um and then it asks the um commissioner
of education
to in his um next biennial budget
to include position for the funding of
the position of the school council
coordinator
as established in the spill the
commissioner may utilize federal funds
for this purpose thank you
representative barry has his hand
oh rep okay representative barry thank
you
i did thank you first of all i don't i
didn't have a copy of the amendment
but but secondly did did anyone
ask the commissioner if he needed that
authority and responsibility
of education um
madam chair representative heath yes um
madam chair um the um commissioner
um did not um let us know
either way but um the um amendment was
passed um out of education and i believe
there was a conversation
with the commissioner at that point in
time but i am not definite about that
thank you uh i see that representative
weiler has his hand up
thank you madam chair i think we don't
need to add any more people to the
to the department of education they have
very many people and in some cases they
interfere with the local districts and
i don't think we've gone years without
this person i don't think
i'm in favor of adding
thank you thank you representative
ford also now has her hand up i see yes
thank you very much madam chair this
policy was
passed in the education department and
we did have
uh department of education people
sitting in our work session
the difficulty is that each
local school district works with
counselors but there's no one to oversee
and no one to support the counselors in
school
unfortunately i think we're going to be
in for a very long
counseling problem we've got kids that
are right now that
are concerned are upset and
may need support as they eventually make
their way back to school to a
physical school and i think we need to
support those kids and we need to
support the teachers
of those kids thank you representative
ford
and i see that uh representative heath
has her hand up
thank you madam chair i just want to
concur with with um division two
susan ford um but i also want to add
i think we are at a point in time like
we've never been in before and there are
more
issues that students are living with
previously the department of ed always
had this position
in place and right now there's no one
that can bring
the uh counselors together in the states
so
i really believe that um we are being um
true to our our mission um by
truly enacting such a position because
it's critical
thank you madam chair yes thank you
representative heath
um further discussion
we are discussing the amendment
representative barry
representative barry yes i'm sorry yeah
thank you madam chair i guess i'm i'm
really confused
that we're passing a requirement that
somebody has to put into next year's
budget
my preference would be to have somebody
speak to the commissioner and
and whoever is responsible for this and
let them bring it forward
during the budget process rather than
thus doing it in
what i consider a clutchy faction
thank you thank you
now i see i see no further hands up
um are we ready for a vote on the
amendment
we're voting on the amendment to house
bill 1549
and it is amendment 10238
i'll ask the representative rogers to
call the role representative hewitt
representative votes yes representative
rogers votes yes representative nordgren
representative nordran valkyos
representative leishman
yes representative yes
represent hatch yes representative ford
yeah representative lovejoy
representative
yes representative murray yes
representative weiler
representative weiler he's thinking
[Music]
uh it looks like he has he seems to have
dropped off dropped off
correct all right look for him
representative ober
no representative danielson
oh representative danielson
no i'm sorry good near you
representative spanos
no representative hennessey
no representative barry no
representative petry no representative
earth
no representative green no
representative weiler are you back with
us i am i do not
okay representative wallner yes
all right madam chairman i have 13 yeses
and
eight no's
the motion passes uh 13 to 8.
now moving on to
the bill as amended i recognize
representative
heath thank you madam chair um i would
like to recommend
ought to pass for house bill 1549 as
amended
second thank you representative keith
moves and we have a second
second representative ford's second
ought to pass as amended
discussion representative heath would
you like to speak
again to them to the motion yes thank
you madam chair um
simply um i just want to
applaud the efforts of education to
bring forward
this position to establish um to
establish
the position of school counseling and
psychology
i think it's an important position and
um hopefully
we'll see it come to be a reality thank
you madam chair
thank you further discussion
i see no hands up no means at this point
okay uh i will ask uh representative
rogers to call the role
the motion is ought to pass as amended
on
uh house bill 1549
representative hewitt representative
votes yes
rogers votes yes nordgren nordgren votes
yes
representative lieschmann yes
representative bucco
yes representative hatch yes
representative ford yes representative
lovejoy
yes representative waltz yes
representative heath
yes representative martin yes
representative murray yes representative
weiler
no representative ober no
representative danielson no
representative spanos no
representative hennessey no
representative barry no representative
petrie
no representative earth no
representative greene no representative
wildner
yes so i think 13 yeses
the motion passes 13 um
four and uh nine against and we'll move
on now to
uh and that one will go on the regular
calendar that now we'll move on
to house bill 1691
and i will call on representative ford
thank you very much madam
chair um i would like to present
amendment to house bill
1691 as 11
1114 h
and i would like to present the
amendment and ask the committee to vote
no unfortunately we had our last meeting
on march 3rd
the times were much different on march
3rd
we would like to be able to present this
but
this bill but it will cost a total of
about eight hundred and fifty thousand
dollars of the educational trust fund
at this point we don't know if we can
pull
851 000 out of the educational trust
fund
and so it becomes very difficult
to support that without having the full
fiscal knowledge of where we are
and mirror motion
representative he seconds the motion
um discussion of the motion
this is on the amendment yes
uh yes representative ober thank you
um may i ask representative ford a
question
yes if she's willing to take a question
thank you
representative ford i understand that
the division voted ought to pass as
amended
prior to the pandemic you're now asking
us to vote no
is it your intention to if this is voted
down
to also vote down to ought to pass and
then to vote
refer for interim study or itl
okay thank you for the clarification
yeah i didn't want to
start that but but that's exactly where
we are now and i think it's very
unfortunate but i also think it's
necessary
and i have talked to all of the division
um two committee members so we
know um they were in agreement that this
is where we are it's just
kind of changed
any i see no further hands up
and so i will ask representative rogers
to
call the role and this is on the
amendment
representative hewitt representative
votes no
representative rogers votes no
representative norgren representative
nordgrenville snow
representative leitchman no
representative
no representative hatch no
representative ford no representative
lovejoy
no representative waltz no
representative heath no representative
martin
no representative murray no
representative weiler no
representative ober no representative
danielson
no representative spanos
no representative hennessey
no representative barry
no representative petry no
representative irf no representative
green
no representative wallner no
developing unanimous 22 nose zero yeses
the motion path um the motion is
um
voted down 22-0 thank you
um and now i move to representative ford
for
a further motion yes um the further
motion would be
to uh vote vote no on
1691 fiscal note
local and mary heath will second that
motion
representative um ford
motion makes a motion uh
for uh um to vote down
ought to pass and representative
heath seconds it we don't do them like
this very often
we don't have situations we use very
often thank god
thank goodness thank goodness um
unless other hands up yes uh
representative barry has to stand up
yes are we are we making it not to pass
motion so we can practice saying no
yes that's exactly what we're doing
thank you for clarifying that for me
i an
if the this goes down i will bring forth
in motion of itl
oh so why i think we have to
i think this has to fail before we go to
itl
right is that correct yes
this has to fail before we go to ito
so this is just we're going through the
recommendations that came
out of going through the recommendations
that came
out of the um division trying to make me
do more work
and we're trying to make it work yes
it's up to how the committee wants to
proceed if they want to just
not make the otp motion and just make
the itl
you're able to do that as well but i'll
leave that up to you
because madam chairman haven't we voted
down the recommendation when we voted
down the
the amendment because the recommendation
was ought to pass as amended
and the chair of division two asked us
to vote no which we did
so that recommendation is really gone
okay so
i would like to bring forth the motion
of inexpedient to legislate
okay represent barry is his hand more
time to say no than he has
okay representative barry all right no
that's what i was going to say thank you
thank you okay so we're going to now
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on house bill 1691
thank you and i'll ask
uh representative rogers to call the
role representative hewitt
representative yord votes uh yes
representative rogers votes yes
representative nordgren
representative yes representative
leishman
yes representative bucco yes
representative hatch yes representative
ford
yes representative lovejoy
yes representative waltz yes
representative yes represent martin
yes representative murray yes
representative weiler yes representative
ober
yes representative danielson
yeah representative spanos
yes representative hennessey
yeah representative barry yes
representative petry yes representative
earth
yes representative greene yes
representative walder yes
the motion is unanimous 22 yes is zero
no
motion passes 22 to zero uh
are you okay with the consent calendar
any objection to the consent no
seeing none we'll put it on consent
thank you division two oh we've still
got one more from division two i'm sorry
now we're moving on to house bill 1698
representative ford thank you rep madam
chair
this is an opportunity to provide equal
access and opportunity for students with
disabilities to participate in
co-curricular activities this came out
of division
two with the five to one in expedient to
legislate
it is not that we are against the policy
the policy is a wonderful idea
i would like to see more and more kids
participate
but it's a fifty thousand dollar amount
that the board that the department of
education would keep in reserve
and um there is no way of knowing how
each individual district would would
get to this money the department of ed
did tell us that if they were to take
this
and to develop the standards
um it would cost that would take
ten thousand dollars out of the bill so
then they'd have forty thousand dollars
what we suggested was that um
that the sponsor
who we we appreciate and we really want
the kids
involved with this take a look at this
and and
um just broaden the plan so that people
would know
exactly how they could access this money
and how
how this money would be spent there is
also
um this is also eligible for for 94142
funding
and there may be a grant and maybe an
opportunity for
the department of education to support
this
with um a grant so the
um motion is inexpedient to legislate
and it's second but seconded by
representative
representative murray yep
do we have to say yes do you want to
speak to your second
no i think she covered it thank you for
asking yes
um any further discussion on
this bill the motion is
um inexpedient to legislate
on house bill 1698 i see no hands up
so i'll ask uh representative rogers to
call the role
representative hewitt representative
votes
yes representative rogers vote yes
representative nordgren
representative norah grinvolt's yes
representative leishman
yes representative bucco yes
representative hatch yes representative
ford
yes representative lovejoy yes
representative walt yes
represent heath yes representative
martin
yes representative murray yes
representative weiler yes representative
ober
jeff representative danielson
yes representative spanos
yes representative hennessey
yeah representative barry sadly
yes representative petery
yes representative yes
representative greene yes representative
wildner
yes madam chairman the vote is 22 yeses
zero knows the motion passes 22 to zero
uh that was house bill 1698
are people fine with us putting that on
the consent calendar
see no objection i will
have it go on consent thank you
moving on now to division three and
thank you division two
for your work and moving now to division
three
and our first um bill is
house bill 1600 and
this bill had work session
but uh the division itself never took a
got to the point where they took a final
vote on it because
we uh the day that we were
supposed to take the final vote in
division
uh we were not and we were already in
ice um
isolation so i will um call on
uh representative norgren for a motion
uh yes i would vote i t uh make a motion
itl
thank you representative morgan do we
have a second
representative hennessy second
representative hennessy seconds
thank you representative um
representative morgan do you want to
speak to your motion of inexpedience
legislate
yes um this bill came to us from the
health human services committee
it's about smoking cessation and giving
the pharmacies
the right to prescribe
and and administrate and
also counsel people who are
wanting to get cessation
medication um we thought for one thing
it should have gone probably to the
commerce committee
after it went to human services
and then us after they vetted it because
this
pharmacies isn't really our bailiwick
um the other issue
is that um there there was an
idea that maybe there would be an
amendment brought in
to change the 100 000 appropriation
to one dollar um i've spoken to the
sponsors many times
and uh felt that that
was sort of unnecessary because
obviously we have no knowledge
of how that would ever happen and
with the looming possibilities of a
great deficit
especially in health and human services
uh
i thought it was unwise and i think
there's been the agreement of division
three
that we should itl this bill
and then i told the sponsors if they
still feel strongly and we know what our
financial situation is they should
resubmit the bill
in september thank you representative
norgren
uh representative uh hennessey would you
like to speak to your second
thank you madam chair yes i just wanted
to add that there
when we were discussing this in division
there were a lot of questions around the
insurance
piece of it and uh just to second
what representative norgren said we
really felt like there was a lot of
policies
decisions that still need to be made and
this would have been better off going to
commerce first
although there is merit with this bill
thank you
thank you representative um further
representative barry has his hand up
thank you madam chair and that
i'd just like to thank representative
nordgren for
the explanation for her going back to
the sponsors and clarifying it with them
that's all thank you thank you thank you
further further questions or
discussion of this bill
seen i see no hands up so
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on
house bill 1600 and i will ask the uh
ask the clerk to call the role
representative hewitt
representative who votes yes
representative rogers votes yes
representative nordgren representative
of nordgrenville
representative leishman yes
representative
yes representative hatch yes
representative ford you have
representative lovejoy
yes representative waltz yes
represent yes representative martin
yes representative murray yes
weiler representative ober
yes representative danielson
yes represents spanos yes
represent hennessey yep
representative barry yes representative
petry
yes representative earth yes
representative greene yes representative
wilder
yes madam sherman the vote is 22 yes's
zero knows
motion passes um the motion was
inexpedient to legislate and the vote
was 22-0
and if there are no objection i will put
this on the consent calendar
see no objection it will go on to
consent
and now we'll move to our final bill
division three bill it's house bill 1638
and i'll call on representative martin
thank you madam chair i'd like to make a
motion
to interim study hb 1638 and then i'd
like to speak to my motion please
representative martin moves to interim
study
um house bill 1638
do we have a second second
and rep representatives hennessy seconds
and would you like to speak to your
motion representative martin
yes thanks madam chair so
just to explain to the committee uh
although division three originally
recommended hb 1638 ought to pass as
amended
um in early march it is a very different
time today as we've all discussed
two and a half months later uh this bill
has a fiscal note of between 150
000 to 300 000 and we know
that given the current fiscal situation
there are no additional funds to
appropriate to the department
that said though since within division
three there was strong
bipartisan support to ensure that more
of our new hampshire snap participants
benefit from healthier eating and access
more local produce
on moving this bill interim study
what was it representative martin moves
interim study on
1638 uh and representative hennessy ii
representative hennessey would like to
speak to your motion to the motion
no representative martin covered it
thank you
okay thank you uh further discussion on
this bill
or questions okay i see no hands up
so uh i'll ask the clerk to call the
role representative hewitt
representative votes yes representative
rogers votes yes representative norgren
representative nerd grenville's yes
representative leishman
yes representative
representative hatch yes represent ford
representative lovejoy yes
representative waltz
yes representative heath yes
representative martin
yes representative murray yes
representative weiler yes representative
albert
yes representative danielson
yeah representative spanos
yes representative hennessey
yeah representative barry yes
represent petrie yes representative
earth
yes rip save green yes
represent wilder yes
madam chairman the vote is 22 yes is
zero knows
the bill um will go for interim study
the vote was 22-0 and
if there are no objection i'd like to
put this on consent calendar
any objections i don't see any so i will
put it on
consent so i think
the next time that we will see these
bills
will be um on june 11th
at the snively arena in durham
um should be an interesting session
we have actually i think we have 11
bills that will be on the calendar that
day
so um we need to
you know get ready for floor fights just
as usual
get ready for floor fights and we need
to have reports
written so we can have them ready for
the
calendar and we do have janet
available to us again she's working
from home but she's been doing a lot of
work for our committee
and um those reports will need to get to
janet
within the next um the next day
probably if we can get them there by
friday so that she can get him into next
week's calendar
any other business to come before the
finance connecticut this time
stay well everybody yeah stay well
great memorial day weekend